hello I'm gav we're the slowmo guys this
video is sponsored by the OnePlus 12
it's a telephone didn't video there I am
I'm filming in my pocket because I
accidentally charged it last night and
one of the main demonstrations is how
fast it charges so I'm just trying to
rinse the battery to demo it later that
makes sense I was thinking about you
know the fast charging the wireless
charging is the coils of wire
electricity moving in a circle and I
thought CDs in a
microwave it was a leap but we've never
filmed in a microwave that is a leap
yeah but I like you just come up with an
excuse to film inside a microwave which
I've always wanted to do however we've
not really been able to do so because
you know it's a microwave can't really
get a camera in there especially not a
phantom it's easier with smaller cameras
but now we can film outside of the
microwave it's true I've kind of done
some research and figured out a way to
do it and we've got some new kit and
equipment that allows us to as well got
some prob lendes and a way to safely
film it from the
outside to avoid glare and allow more
lighting I've taken the glass off the
front of this microwave CU otherwise
it's kind of tricky to film inside I've
also drilled a hole here in this mesh
now this mesh usually is just to stop
the microwaves from passing through out
to past the door of the microwave now
microwaves are actually 12 cm long sort
of wavelengths like this which means
that these tiny little holes are a
little bit Overkill so we can easily get
away with a hole like this is it mental
that a microwave is 12 cm long yeah it
is in in in wavelength that it's so much
bigger than I imagined how big are are
like visible light waves um I think
green is 540 nanm or something well this
is 12 CM that's exactly what I mean it's
like it's so far at the other end wow
480 nanm might be blue I don't know I
love that you know
that it's like fully expecting you to be
like I don't know but you're like I
think blue actually all right I'm a
nerd do you know what I love about you
YouTube there's there's actually really
good videos out there on specifically
how to film inside a microwave yeah I
did actually um look at a few of those
for research purposes you watched a bit
of our boy mold out there I did watch
moldy bit of Steve mold I flopped on the
old probe blend quite a bit bigger than
the hole but if we press up right
against it there shouldn't be too much
vignetting let's grab a cheeky 4K shot
at
1,000 5 4 3 2
okay I don't think my line wire
downloads are going to go on there
anymore oh oh it's like a it's like a
lightning storm in the dark you know at
night yeah some real like Tron Vibes
yeah it's like the opening of a portal
or something so we're clearly seeing the
uh the alternating current cuz it's
happening every 60th of a sec second
it's coming on and then off oh
interesting that's something you'd never
see not in slowmo all right so why don't
we take a look at it with all the gaps
cut you ready yep
oh that looks cool that's cooler I've
never seen it like that so the arcing is
blue and then plasma is red it looks
like green green some bright ones there
absolute laser show yeah I like the fact
that it's still circular like with the
CD I thought it would just jump kind of
any angle but it shows the sort of
circular parts of the CD seems to start
from the outside all right now with all
the gaps out let's overlay all of it to
happen at the same time pretty much
ready
yep
it looks like um the activation of like
the Infinity Stones or something do you
know what I mean should have aimed for
the head
yeah it says
here do not operate with object an
object caught in the door yeah there
isn't
one a door that does not close properly
it close is fine close is just
fine 5 4 3 2
[Music]
okay Switching to the TMX at 10,000
frames a
second 4 3 2
[Music]
ooh yeah looks like laser etching
doesn't it that does that's it's being
graved by tiny little robot lasers like
a CNC sort of thing it's very clever
there's a lot bigger gaps in some places
like from the outside you can see a huge
gap in the sort of surface of the CD
with a plastic show through it's it's
like as soon as there's a eruption of
plasma all of the energy is focused
there and you don't get a lot of
simultaneous Sparks oh that's true
without the Puffs you wouldn't be able
to see that it's a CD yeah like it can't
go at 45° really it can only go
perpendicular or veral I've never seen
it like this never seen it in this
detail it's explosions out it's like
ejecting material it's it's really
interesting to see the speed difference
between the spark travel and the little
eruptions okay 10 was good but why are
we down at 10 when we could be at 80
that's what I always say that's the
question I always wonder I always ask
myself
that
stop oh yeah you can see it kind of goes
back and forth and it is just individual
dots it's like and it's and it's not
really it doesn't necessarily like
follow a path in the same space like do
a little bit here jump up there come
back down here yeah is it like lightning
where it goes back and forth all the
time is that what's happening I don't
know it's like little Morse code bits
sort of like it is just like a a laser
engraver that's exactly what it looks
like I wonder if you could do this you
know a billion times it be different
every single time oh that was
interesting the the spark stayed in the
same place for a while there it's just
started working on the same spot and
that caused the eruption was interest
interesting when something like less
visually cool actually gives you more
information this just looks like dots
but it's actually quite interesting the
way it's like the way it's deciding to
go yeah it's not that any decisions are
being made but it seems to be there's
more more plasma the further on we go is
you're right like it Heats it and heats
it and heats it and then it gets then
you start getting more plasma yeah I
think it this The Sweep spot for the the
way this looks like the coolest is at
slightly lower frame rate because then
more occurs in each frame you end up
with lines instead of dots Ah that's
true I think it looks cooler too there's
definitely a sweet spot with the frame
rate yeah it's one of those rare things
that looks cool in real time and then as
you step up the frame rate it still
looks cool but you're seeing different
things each time yeah I'm going to use
the OnePlus for an internal view strap
it up tiny little hassle blad is what it
is
[Music]
yeah
St a good amount of Destruction yeah
solid but not enough not not not enough
yeah I think uh we've done a lot of eggs
exploding and being shot and things like
that before but it's always been there's
there always been a cause like a visual
cause yeah whereas with the microwave
they just sort of spontaneously combust
it seems like the pressure builds up and
inside the shell and then explodes I
don't think I've ever put an egg in the
microwave in my life have you not no you
know to draw any any funny face on the
egg or
anything that's one of us does he got
standard ears no ears no no ears hang on
oh perfect all right let's see him
ripped open from the inside
to use one word one word to describe
this it would be
perfect hopefully the egg is cooked by
the microwave and not these
lights can you already see it my got
[Laughter]
show ready yep it's getting sweaty it's
getting
sweaty quite a lot of cooked egg
showing okay
W
flip I think it's like done the
microwave in look at
it
holy the thing is it's not even viscous
it's cooked it so much it's just cooked
egg it's just cooked it like I've seen
the videos before where it's kind of
liquidy and viscous and it sort of
explodes
this was just scrambled egg at a million
miles hour that's some intensely strong
egg
there
oh I'd not seen that before did you just
go all over yourself in in amazement I
did that was the longest I've seen it go
in the
microwave that's just scrambled it's
just fully scrambled it it doesn't smell
as bad as I was
expecting
it's definitely
overcooked just a nice egg you can
barely tell it's spitting we're filming
so fast oh yeah you have to look at it
for a few seconds to
realize wow there was like a primary
explosion and a secondary one if you
look I can't believe so much pressure
can build up doesn't appear to be
working just just completely ended the
microwave well that's a positive means I
don't have to clean the microwave should
you break out the spare microwave I
think so should I get some different
less powerful eggs as well no these eggs
are great these eggs are great I know
what to talk about do you want to do you
on the front me on the back sure I guess
this can be
me just a regular size nose
here cheers for
that I'm I've got I've got the subject
right in front of me
so it's not particularly well shaven
beard
there we
go okay I think whoever blows up loses I
think it's a win really cuz you get
immortalized okay so the winner blows up
the winner blows up
okay I think our Channel's
devolving you think uh when did it start
going downhill when when did I join the
channel that's
me back round to you there we go oh oh I
think I think that's it that is
definitely it looked like a gruesome
head
shot so
quick
oh that's so much less violent
now oh wow it's like a tidal wave you
know in like a water pressure overcomes
sort of a barrier oh that one just
peeled open open everyone's completely
different you can see the little cooked
areas in there yeah are you making my
schnozes bigger I was wondering if you
were going to notice but I'm trying to
very subtly make them slightly bigger
each time let me know if it starts
sweating yeah
oh just
went I think that was you oh yeah I
think you just got a
visery blood bar
well I don't know your eyes look like
you've already
been do you put a g in your mouth oh oh
oh that was a forceful one but
undercooked still that one looks really
cool that's my favorite one oh straight
through the eyebrow just the patterns in
the liquids yeah that's entirely
dependent on the shell that one hasn't
so much burst as that one exploded more
it's like it's like that scene in um
license to kill oh yeah sure the Yol got
out of there as well look got those tiny
flexs of cooked egg yeah pretty Grim
pretty
Grim there you go just the eventually
detected that as a
face well that was gruesome oh oh a
dripping egg on you I'm sorry I like how
quickly we went straight to eggs which
have really nothing to do with
electricity right we've done the
electricity part eggs blow up some egg
do you know what I like the the variety
of different eggs did different things
yeah like it every egg was different
yeah every single one well there we have
it hopefully you enjoyed that
destruction big thanks once again to
OnePlus for sponsoring this video you
can check out the OnePlus 12 at the link
in the description and I would now like
to tell you slightly more things about
the phone on the screen right now is a
real time screen capture of how fast it
charges 80 Watts when plugged in 80
Watts 80 Watts I feel like my electric
car at home doesn't charge that fast I
actually don't think it does the iPhone
I believe is 25
which is what I'm used to OnePlus 12 has
the fastest wired and wireless charging
in North America 1 to 100% in 30 minutes
with 80 W wired charging 50 W wireless
charging that can charge from 1 to 50%
in 23 minutes if you started charging
your OnePlus 12 from 3% at the beginning
of this video it would now be
approximately 61% charged features
qualcomm's latest chipset with 16 GB of
RAM which means you can have up to 47
apps open at the same time that is a
very specific amount of apps it is I was
like 47 the thing is I never closed the
apps as well it also features a triple
lens camera that's made in collaboration
with Hasselblad has a three times
optical zoom and 120 times digital Zoom
that is that's that's in there
considerable thanks once again for
watching make sure you subscribe if you
like slow-mo and we'll see you next time
bye-bye